Leadership is about your team,
and about the people,
and about creating constructs and frameworks
for them to fully realize their vision.
Diane Boettcher, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
I'm good, thank you.
Thanks for having me.
Pleasure to be here.
Thank you very much for joining me.
We have so much to talk about
in so little time
because we are going to talk about
your experience in the military
in the technology side,
being deployed overseas to Afghanistan
but transitioning to being a keynote speaker
and leading with kindness.
And when I think of
a military setting in Afghanistan,
transitioning to a keynote speaking
of leading with kindness,
there's going to be a little bit,
I'm sure there's a dissonance there.
But then, being an architect manager
at Microsoft, so a lot of experiences
that I want to learn from.
But I'd like to start
with the hardest question, which is
tell me a little bit about yourself
and where you come from?
So, a great question.
As you could probably guess from my accent,
I am American, although,
I used to lived most of my adult life
outside of the continental US.
Some of that due to my military career,
some of it due to my civilian career.
So, yeah, like you said,
pretty diverse background.
I think of myself,
earlier you've mentioned my title
as an architect manager.
I think of myself as a leader
more than as a manager.
And we always say that
we manage things and lead people right.
And both need to be that.
Leaders and organizations
need to be paying attention
to both sides of that.
Because you always have to manage budgets
and time and resources
and things like that.
But people should never be thought of
as things and so we lead people.
And so, yeah,
I joined the Navy right out of college.
I went to flight school.
Not a pilot, though.
Most of the time when I say
I flew reconnaissance aircraft,
people go, "Oh, you're a pilot." No.
So, a lot of people have seen Top Gun.
So Maverick and Goose, right? Goose.
I was in the back, we're on a mission,
hovering out, "Do some of that pilot stuff."
Diane, I have to go back a little bit
because the thing that I enjoy most
about this show is really
understanding the junctions
and the decision making processes.
Correct me if I'm wrong,
but it's not the default path
for many young women out of college
to go to flight school in the Navy,
especially in a technological position.
Sure. Sure.
Okay, so, I consider myself
one of the first digital natives.
Both of my parents
work for a computer company
when I was growing up.
And back then computers took up rooms.
And a college might,
a college might have one computer.
And in fact, that's what my mother did.
My mother has a background in education
and she sold computers
to engineering school.
So, they weren't really sure
they needed a computer, right?
They've been teaching engineering
for many years and they weren't sure
they needed a computer to do it.
And the CEO of the company,
a man named Mr. Morris, believed computers
were going to change the world
and they belonged to the homes.
And everybody thought that was crazy.
And they said, "What would they do with it?"
"What would you do
with a computer in your house?"
And he's like, "Well, I don't know."
"So, let's give them to people."
And so he reached out to his employee base
and he said, "Who has young children?"
And he gave us mainframe terminal.
So, I was about 10 or 11 years old
and we got a mainframe terminal in my house.
This was an old three hundred baud
classical modem.
We were like pounding it into the cradle.
And we did what teenagers do.
We played games and act the voice.
So, I was very early on
exposed to technology,
exposed to that kind of
part of the world, if you will.
And so, when I graduate from college,
I was joining the Navy,
this was late 80's, mid 80's,
very much appreciative of the freedoms
that we enjoy here in the United States.
Felt it was important
to put my hand at the wheel,
take my turn at the [--], if you will,
and join the military, so I did.
And then it was like, well, actually,
at the time women weren't allowed on
to serve on ships.
But there was some interesting things
happening in the aviation side of the house.
And so, that's why I decided to go there.
Wow. Okay.
So, and how long did you serve for?
I actually just retired.
Between active duty and reserves
I've served 30 years.
Wow. 30 years.
So, I have to all of a sudden jump
a little bit, because today,
I'm going to skip for now
about the leading with kindness.
We'll come back to this.
But I have to now talk about
being a leader at Microsoft,
being a leader in the Navy,
deployed overseas,
managing critical infrastructure
at both companies,
different types of infrastructure, I'm sure,
and different technologies, I'm sure.
What were some commonalities
and some differences that you're seeing?
Oh, yeah.
So, the couple of places
where I was managing infrastructure.
So, in addition to being deployed
to Afghanistan as a civilian,
I managed the network in Germany
as well as one on the continent of Africa
and a little country called Djibouti,
which we just have to admit
it's from the side.
So, and I think that one of the things
that is common across is that
we've really moved from seeing technology
as an extra as it was when I was young
to being infrastructure, right?
That we can no longer think of technology
as Internet access of the capabilities
that are brought to us with technology
as a nice to have.
They are a must-have.
It's powering the war. It really is.
At the same time,
We don't see the,
I don't see the operators, right?
So, whether that's the people
who fly the aircraft to pick up the weapons
in the military or in a business context,
would be your sellers,
your customer engagement,
really understanding
what's happening with the technology.
And so, as a leader in technology,
a lot of times
what we were spending our energy on
is helping those business leaders,
helping those operational leaders
understand the capabilities
and the constraints
that the technology brings to it.
So, for example, in the military,
we would often have to talk
to some of the senior leaders
about how we had to,
you know we have to take down the servers
and do patched maintenance on them.
So, this was before the cloud
and before virtual machines.
And we would actually have to take,
have an outage in order to update
and install the patches on the servers.
And we have to explain
to very senior people
that we would have to take down the system.
And a lot of times they,
"Why I never have to do that
with my router at home?"
"Well, yes, sir."
"That's because your router at home
is your own."
The adversary, probably, is on it.
Because you've never patched it.
And we don't want that happening
to our servers, so we have to take it down.
And so, then we would try to say,
"Well, you know, you wouldn't fly
an aircraft for 30 days without maintain."
"You wouldn't fire a weapon for 60 days
without taking disassembling it
and cleaning it and maintaining it, right?
"Oh, right."
"Yeah, okay."
"Well, we have to do that
with the technology as well."
And so a lot of,
both in business and in military,
a lot of what it is,
is helping those business leaders,
helping the operational leaders understand
both the limitations and the capabilities,
what are the cool things they can do
with the technology.
I'd love to transition a little bit
in talking about leadership
as we continue on your journey.
So, you finished your duty, right?
You're still in reserved duty
but you've finished your active duty.
And you are now trying
to be a keynote speaker
and help others understand better
leading with kindness.
What does that mean?
So, it's got dual meanings, right?
So, first of all,
it's being about being a kind leader, right?
It's about leading isn't about yelling.
Leading isn't about
the being the one in charge.
Leading is about being kind.
It's also a little bit of a double standard
that when you lead with something,
it's the thing that comes first, right?
So, it's showing up first with kindness.
Like whatever else comes along,
the kindness needs to show first.
And I think a lot of people misunderstand
the way the military leads.
You've served,
the other people who've served understand that
it's not just about yelling orders,
it's about helping people share the vision.
Like understand what are we doing here,
what are we trying to accomplish.
And then getting other people's way
and letting their creativity,
their passion, their innovation,
their energy make that vision come true.
And you can't do that
if people don't share the vision
and they're not going to share
the vision with you
if you're mean to them.
It's just as simple as that.
Why so passionate about this?
Where does this innate passion
that you're saying
I want to dedicate myself now
to sharing this passion with others,
where does this come from?
I think well, I think our world lacks leaders,
and I think our world lacks
the good examples of leaders.
I think too many people learn about
what it's like to be a leader
through the media, through Hollywood,
through fictional depictions.
And a fictional depiction of
Eisenhower standing with those paratroopers
the night before D-Day
and just talking with them.
That's not dramatic, right?
That doesn't sell tickets, right?
So, we end up with the cake box boss
yelling at people.
And we end up thinking that
that's what leadership is.
And it's not.
It's not.
But the quiet, humble leaders
who are out there doing the hard work
of getting to know their people
and helping their people,
lifting their people up,
we don't see that portrayed.
So, we have this misunderstanding
of what it means to lead and be a leader.
And I think we lack that in our communities,
we lack that in our schools,
we lack that in our workplaces.
And it doesn't have to be like that.
Work doesn't have to be terrible.
We spend so much of our day at work.
Why would we want it to be a turmoil?
Why would we want it to be so difficult?
Why can't it be?
And I think it can.
I think it can be a place
where we grow and we thrive
and we bring our full,
and complete authentic selves.
So, where does that come from?
This comes from a look
that could be so much better.
We could have some fun at work.
We could accomplish so much.
We can all win.
Life isn't a competition, right?
I am a gamer too.
That's not in my bio
but I play games all the time with my kids
and everything.
And we play co-op games.
And a co-op game is a game
where we all work together
to beat the game,
not to beat each other.
And that's what life is.
Life's a co-op game.
We can all win.
Right. Diane, as I'm embarking
on my journey,
and I hope to have the privilege
of leading great teams
with fantastic, motivated,
intelligent, hardworking people,
what are some things
that I can take with me from this conversation
for the next few decades
as hopefully a successful leader?
What things should I be keeping in mind
that you're observing that are just
not apparently enough in the world?
So, leadership isn't about you.
Leadership is about your team,
and about the people,
and about creating constructs and frameworks
for them to fully realize their vision.
And as the leader, what you do is
you set the overall larger vision
and then you help people understand
how they can achieve their purpose
In that context.
And then, when I said create the frameworks
that allows them to have those
to bring their passion,
their innovation, their creativity, right?
Because those are the things
you can't automate.
Those are the things, you know,
if it's something where,
I always hear from my people,
it's, "Well, tell me what to do."
I said, "Well, I could do that,
I would write an algorithm."
And I would just have the algorithm do it.
What I need from you is
to figure out what I don't know, right?
So, listen to your people.
Understand that they're full
and complete human beings right there,
more than what they bring to work.
And so, understand what those
other things are about them
and what's important to them
and support them in that.
And then share your vision
and clearly communicate your vision
over and over and over and over again.
The best leaders are those whose people
can imitate them flawlessly.
If your people
can do a good imitation of you,
it means you're showing up,
it means you're being consistent, right?
I love that. I love that.
Because, you know,
a lot of the people that I speak to,
I ask this question a lot
and a lot of the times
I'm hearing responses like,
a good leader is one that knows
how to hire slow and fire fast.
Or a good leader is one that knows
how to articulate the vision
and take the team forward.
Rarely, the first response is
a good leader is one who listens
and one who serves by example
and has their people yearning to
or able to imitate their positive qualities,
like showing up and being consistent.
So, I'm taking a lot of this inspiration.
And I have to say that
from my experience in the military,
I've gotten to observe
great leaders, poor leaders.
I've gotten to be a leader myself.
I have been a good leader.
I have been a poor leader.
And I've learned from both.
And it's a journey that I'm very excited
to continue embarking on.
And in the end people is everything.
We just have a few minutes left.
But I'd love to learn a little bit about
what you're doing today at Microsoft,
what you chose as your next challenge.
And then obviously, the last was
a difficult question that I'll ask,
Okay. Yes, I was an architect manager.
I lead a small team of pretty senior folks,
which is really exciting.
All of them have 15, 20 years
of industry experience.
And what they do is they help our customers
who are solving the hardest problems
with our technology.
So, whether it's typically we're talking
Fortune 50 type of customers
who are doing big things or new things
with our technologies
and the architects in my team
help them do that.
And so that what my job is,
is to make sure that
they have everything they need
to show up well for our customers
and help our customers succeed.
So, it sounds like an amazing challenge
that consistently changes,
consistently having to adapt,
because obviously we're seeing
how the world is changing every single day.
And Microsoft is at the forefront
of these changes.
And I'm sure that
it's a pretty remarkable position.
Diane, I want to thank you again
for being so generous with your time.
And I'd love to end with my favorite question,
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Yeah. So I'm candid.
To all of my friends I'm candid.
I'm founded in knowledge.
I like to do my homework.
And then the last is compassion.
I can definitely see that.
Yeah.
I love that.
And I want to, again,
thank you for sharing your journey.
I think it's remarkable
and I'm learning so much from every journey.
But that transition from the military setting,
the technological background
going there with a mission,
being a part of missions,
and then going and talking
about leading with kindness
and expressing that side
and then doing it in a place like Microsoft,
I'm sure that's just phenomenal.
And I'm sure that those architects
are lucky to have you working with them.
So, Diane, thank you very very much.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
Thank you, you too.
All right, thanks.